I I had to cut it out I I have a year
and a half sober
on April 26th of this month from
marijuana and alcohol because it uh
it just made me really irresponsible
and I I have a self-hatred that I've
been working on for a long time you need
to or something in me it's not even me I
believe in the principle I'm very
spiritual so like I believe in
principalities in your head telling you
you should go kill yourself
um and then you have to combat that with
really good behavior and believe that
either people or God love you in my case
I believe both do yeah uh so you have to
rewrite and feed that narrative
um and alcohol is like opening the
floodgates for the voices so if I was
really drunk it was like man you are
gross and no one will ever want to marry
you and you're a disappointment and you
should kill yourself
and I was like well that's not a tenable
narrative that's not sustainable
um and so yeah I feel way better man I
feel I feel great now well I always say
that like I always tell some of my
friends who you know they they drink too
much they you know and I'm you're their
friend you just [__] say something
you know if you're a good friend yeah
and I do I call people out I just
[__] call them out yeah like I I
drink occasionally there's a there's I'm
70 on that I would say three out of ten
friends I'm like
I'm kind of letting them work through it
or I'm afraid they're not going to
receive it but then the other seven out
of 10 I'm like I took my a friend of
mine was doing coke one time in front of
me and offered it to me I've been
offered Coke like six or seven times
never done it because I was afraid
because my heroes Chris Farley I'm not
trying to me too oh my God it's fine all
the time
yeah we could talk but but I I kind of
pulled him aside and was like hey I know
you just booked this pilot and I know
you got some money and and the show's
getting picked up but like this is a
quick way to
[__] on this cold and opportunity and I
care about you and I love you that's it
you just kind of
do that out there and then and I would
rat now I would rather them be mad at me
and sever some Tire create some distance
and know that I said something yeah now
that's important to me yeah but it's
tough it is it's tough I think
some people
should not drink
some people should not drink now when I
say some people shouldn't have kids like
that yeah uh yeah listen there are there
are there are unique circumstances in
which people should not be involved in
something yeah I said to this person in
particular I said
when you drink how of all the things
that you regret and most of the things
what percentage happens or bad decisions
when you're doing drugs and you're
drinking when you're snowing they said
probably almost all of them
and I was like well I I don't need to
say anything else
your problems will you'll still have
problems but they'll be easier to deal
with they won't be magnified yeah and
that's uh it's hard also problems but
get problems right and people forget
that like there is a very con
hyper-constructive chain reaction of
events that happen where it's like I'm
drunk uh now I'm kind of I kind of want
to get high now I kind of want to order
food now I just spent 80 bucks on
Postmates for a burger and fries now
we've all done it and then it's like now
I feel like [__] now I'm I have diarrhea
from the burger now I'm gonna be
hungover I have work tomorrow holy [__]
did I buy Imagine Dragon concert tickets
am I going to see Imagine Dragons did I
buy it for the wrong venue did you do
that
you son of a [__] is a true story
I bought so there's two what is the
place the outdoor venue that's in uh up
in the hiking area the Greek the Greek
yeah I bought tickets for some concert
it was the national actually it wasn't
it wasn't well that's good I bought
Imagine Dragons tickets for the wrong
night
that that's what happened I went to the
Palladium and I it was one of the worst
concerts I've ever been to I hated it
and I don't know why I bought into their
freaking
Illuminati choruses